hello everyone I'm Dana Perino along
with Shannon bream Harold Ford Jr Jesse
Waters and Greg Gutfeld It's Five
O'Clock in New York City this is the
five
[Music]
right now former president Donald Trump
arriving at the airport in D.C after his
third criminal arraignment Trump
pleading not guilty to four charges over
allegations he tried to overturn the
2020 election the former president is
denying any wrongdoing and accusing
special counsel Jack Smith of engaging
in quote election interference the
spokesperson for Trump's legal team
sounding off outside the courthouse
earlier
this is election interference at its
finest against the leading candidate
right now for president for either party
president Trump is under siege in a way
that we have never seen before people
are afraid of somebody that cannot be
bought by Washington people are afraid
of somebody who is independently wealthy
and who has given up his good life to
fight for this country and that
frightened a lot of politicians who are
career politicians unfortunately we have
seen them try and tie up and me as an
attorney have never seen this tie up one
individual who's a campaign who's
running a campaign in a campaign running
for office for president so that he is
in court in depositions and distracted
so that he won't properly run for 2024
and frankly it's not going to work so
president Trump has left Washington D.C
that's him there pulling up to the plane
so that he can go back to Bedminster New
Jersey and Shannon bream is with us
thankfully Chief legal correspondent and
of course Fox News Sunday host so what
was that bottom line today there was no
gag order put on the president not that
I've heard of from this hearing today
and that would be really tenuous I've
asked his legal team about this before
what happens if you get a gag order you
and I have talked about it we discussed
with Neil last hour the fact that every
one of his rallies his speeches is built
around this idea that Washington The
Establishment the quote deep state is
coming after him he is what stands
between the voters and those guys and so
it's unimaginable that a judge would
tell him you got a gag order you can't
talk about any of these cases because
that is at the Crux of every speech he
gives there would be a knock down drag
out legal fight with plenty of appeals
if that happens but the judge's purview
is to set the parameters of exactly how
this works it looks like we are in Hot
Pursuit of students yes
Christine to try to get over to where
the president has just gotten out of the
vehicle and let's see here uh I just see
some shoes but
this was this is called the pool this is
the Press pool Jesse that they are there
because you know as I've said on Neil
Cavuto show as somebody else pointed out
to me I just feel like the justice
department has not won these news Cycles
the past three days they might have won
necessarily like on other networks but
in the court of public opinion I don't
think this case landed the way they
thought it would none of them have
and so usually he doesn't speak at the
tarmac last time he went back to
Bedminster and spoke
and now it looks like it's drizzling so
I'm not sure he's going to like those
Optics but I think the the country would
like to hear from him because there's
been a significant build up here this
buildup has been a little different than
the brag in even the Mar-A-Lago case
this January 6 case seems a little bit
more
dark and we expect hopefully to hear
from him I'd like to hear from him but
everything that has come out so far has
landed with a dud and the timing of all
of these legal actions has really
benefited him he was laying low and then
all of a sudden they bust into
Mar-A-Lago and the whole country woke up
and thought Oh my God this is serious
and no one likes that and then the
Republicans win the house and then they
get subpoena power and start finding out
all these scandalous things about the
Biden family and then what do you know
the brag indictment comes in everyone
can't wait to see it you look in the
indictment
and it's a pile of garbage Jesse I think
the president is going to make a
statement Okay let's listen in
well thank you very much this is a very
sad day for America and it was also very
sad driving through Washington DC and
seeing the filth and the Decay and all
of the broken buildings and walls and
the graffiti this is not the place that
I left it's a very sad thing to see it
when you look at what's happening this
is a persecution of a political opponent
this was never supposed to happen in
America this is the persecution of the
person that's leading by very very
substantial numbers in the Republican
primary and leading Biden by a lot so if
you can't beat him you persecute him or
you prosecute them we can't let this
happen in America thank you very much
elect you want these trials to happen
all right there you have the statement
basically sad day he made a point of
pointing out how filthy Washington DC is
and the empty buildings is not wrong
there of course he says it is a
political persecution of the person
who's running against Joe Biden that
this should never happen in America and
yet Jesse I'll let you finish your
thought here because just chuckling at
the graphic description of the venue
have it be filthy and he didn't leave it
that way
but he seemed loose to me he seemed calm
steady loose uh you know this is his
third indictment I would have probably
been wetting myself uh but again this is
now something after the raid and then
after you find about uh Joe Biden and
and then you looked at the Alvin Bragg
indictment and and everybody was
scratching their head like this doesn't
even make any legal sense and so that
happens and then by this January 6th
indictment
we're kind of tired of it and all of
them on the media they say oh my God
this is the biggest this is airtight and
then you look at it and everybody says
Ho Hum but
the drama unfolding on the screen really
benefits this guy they follow him around
like it's like the the Bronco chase you
got cameras in the in the pursuing him
reporters are tripping over themselves
on wet tarmacs I just and Biden's on
vacation he's passed out at the beach
I'm not sure they're winning the the
media War I guess we'll we'll have to
see what happens in the courtroom Greg
Gutfeld you've been watching all day not
really no I've been pretty much hanging
around uh yeah yo uh did you ever hear
the Gutfeld rule that uh the value of
something gets smaller with each
iteration and I think that's what you're
seeing with uh uh with these indictments
as well it's what happened with
impeachments is that they just get
smaller and smaller and smaller the
value becomes less because they're more
mundane uh obviously here they just go
too far they go too far they're going to
do it again and they're going to do it
again and he's right and Jesse's right
there's a pattern of indictment it
always follows something else if I was
Trump's lawyer it's so easy just say if
it's a crime to say that I've been
cheated out loud then we better start
building a whole bunch of super max
prisons with an exclusive wing for Obama
Hillary John Kerry Stacy Abrams throw in
some professional baseball players some
High School coaches high-stake poker
players throw me there okay because I
sold I sold the most books this week in
America and the New York Times put me at
number six they cheated why they cheated
him lock me up go for it I dare you to
but the point is is it irrational to
think that an election can be unfair I
think it's a bit Rich when you see
things that have been happening for the
last four years whether it is Russian
collusion or it's how they hid the
laptop the 52 experts
um
there's there's a lot of weird stuff
going on and I think Real World
Experience teaches you that things
everything every institution can be
corrupted can be exploited the Biden
family has showed us that clearly that
you know politics everything Finance you
know I think what bothers me is the
media spent decades saying how every
system is rigged right the justice
system Housing Finance the defense
industry the cops everything is broken
everything is broken except the
elections when we win right then it's
pristine it's impervious to cheating you
know we we don't know if the election by
and large with 50 states it was
corrupted or what not it's unprovable
but it's uh it can't be proven either
way so I don't understand how you can
actually prove this or read his mind
when it comes to something like this
twistful thinking Harold Ford Jr people
have missed your voice uh you were back
here around the table and it's so good
to have you here what do you I think the
Democrats are thinking today I don't
know it's good to be back though and I
listened to president Trump he has an
amazing calmness about him uh he's
probably he's experienced some of these
things uh facing a lot of turmoil and a
lot of difficulty as presidents are
um he's innocent until proven guilty one
of the more I think refreshing things to
hear Jack Smith say in his presentation
in the recitation of what he's doing a
day or two ago was that the president uh
is innocent and they have to prove the
case
two I lost a race for the U.S Senate
about 17 years ago and it was a close
race
um there were those people some in my
state and some of my campaign who
actually thought we won now I could have
gone around telling people that we won
and that I'd been robbed of the race
which would be fine and that would be
protected speech
but if I picked up the phone and called
three democratic election officials in
counties that I had won and said look
find me 25 000 votes
I think that's what's at stake here and
I don't know all the facts I was learned
today as I listened to Andy macarthy who
I think is as good as anybody on any
network I only watch Fox but as good as
anybody on any network analyzing this
legally note that Shannon's great our
whole team is great but I think his
experience in the Justice Department is
fantastic he he has even indicated that
uh that it may be that Jack Smith has
more than we know at the moment
uh Greg I'd say one thing about the
elections I I did I agree with you on so
many things but on on Election Integrity
remember 60 judges or 60 uh courts a
rejected president Trump's come down
your point is we cannot know if
everything is done correctly and I would
agree with that we should look at it
right well none of those guys looked at
it that's not true some of those courts
some of those courts did and I it's it's
so unfortunate I think tragic that we
oftentimes preface when we talk about
courts with that was a judge show was
appointed by this person or that person
remember judges like anybody in elected
office take an oath of office and and
Central to that oath fundamental to that
oath is uphold the Constitution so I
believe that any judge be they are
appointed by George W H W Obama Trump
whomever they may Clint whomever that
they're going to try to that they're
going to uphold the law finally
um in this case here remember whether we
like or agree with attorney general Barr
that was his attorney general he
believes that President Trump knew these
things vice president Pence believes
when I say these things he believes that
President Trump knew that he had lost
this race and that he was acting with
some intentionality these are things
that they're saying and I would imagine
that these people likely are going to be
called by Jack Smith during the course
of this case one thing I do agree
wholeheartedly with what president Trump
said as he got on the plane there was
that this is a tough day and a terrible
day for the country and I hope that
they're able to get to a trial as soon
as it is suitable for both sides Jesse
for the president to be prepared and it
seems as if the government is prepared
and I hope that they're able to go
through this in a way that that delivers
Justice for the country and for those
involved yeah that's it's Harold just
attacked me like I've never seen in my
life I would like to respond to him okay
okay
um I think you can question the judges
and the jury because I don't think this
is normal I don't think this case is
normal this isn't like a offender Bender
between Paparazzi and Wayne Newton I
mean this is the president of the United
States that was portrayed as Hitler in
the media so you know the entire jury
pool and the judges are poisoned I mean
how can like if you're a judge or you're
a jury and you've been for five years
and I said this on the five I think two
years ago I said if work if everybody's
saying that this guy's Hitler there's
got to be something wrong with you if
you don't rig the election there's got
to be something wrong with you if you
aren't biased if you're on a jury and
Hitler's there of course you don't care
if he's innocent of this particular
thing that dude Taylor you got to get
rid of him and I think that you know for
five years this guy has been Hitler
there's no way that you can get around
that I think up to your other point um
you can know that you lost an election
but still think it was
crooked but if you act to try to undo
the election is all I'm saying I call
people and said let's find some more
votes here because I know we've won and
if you that's the only point I was
asking let's ask our legal eagle okay
again she's here there's a lot of cases
that were never heard on the merits I
mean they were tossed on early motions
um other technicalities so a lot of
these cases didn't get to the marriage
some of them did
um but I think that the president's
legal team meaning president Trump felt
like a lot of these things were
unresolved their efforts to get things
done at the Supreme Court yeah got to
get at least forced justices to vote to
hear a case there they didn't do it so
they feel like there were a lot of you
know angles and lanes that were left to
them but I think it's interesting that
it seems that Democrats are getting more
and more concerned about what they've
pushed for which I think is to make
Trump the nominee because they think
he's going to be the easiest one to beat
now when they see him surging and him
joking on social media about I just need
that fourth indictment it's going to
ensure my re-election they're getting
nervous in Playbook I think it was today
there was a private lunch with President
Obama and President Biden that was
leaked where he warned him like you've
got to take Trump serious why was that
late why was that private lunch and who
leads that to Playbook I think that the
left is getting seriously worried about
they've created this monster meaning
they want multiple indictments they want
them tied up in all these I imagine that
the Laker is somebody from Obama's team
yeah that wants to make it clear that
Obama's warning we're taking this
serious can I ask you one thing though
about this question I agree yeah Smith
wouldn't he have put all that he had
into this indictment with the court of
public opinion being like this
unprecedented would he actually hold
back all of these other like supposedly
great nuggets and evidence then
presented trial he would hold it back
it's possible that not everything is in
the indictment that's that's clear it
could be hundreds of pages long then but
think about former Attorney General Bill
Barr in an interview last night said he
is convinced that there is a lot more
that Jack Smith has that he hasn't put
out there remember when former vice
president Pence was forced to testify to
one of these grand juries we saw the
transcript there were 18 consecutive
Pages at one point blacked out so there
are a lot of questions about what else
did Pence have to say what else don't we
know that's been held behind closed
doors and for the grand jury to this
point
um and again would you present to a
grand jury and how you do this at trial
very different there's no one defending
the defendant at the Grand Jury hearing
so when you get to trial we'll we'll see
a lot more do you guys want to see some
Democrats losing their minds
I love America
talking about Sonny if they make it he
makes a deal with Smith without jails
and without you he says look I'm going
away I'm moving to Saudi Arabia I just
want him to go away and stop ruining my
country
agreement without time if he would agree
to never run for public office again
anywhere democracy itself is really at
issue in this trial if Trump could get
away with what he's done uh what he's
charged with here then we don't have the
Democracy we believe we had to me this
is really going to be about whether
people in this country care about the
facts in the law it would be well if the
end of our democracy if Donald Trump was
able to get back into office
Jesse Waters that was just a sampling of
the reaction they said that after the
midterms remember democracy was supposed
to be over if the Republicans won the
house so we don't have one technically
right now if you listen to them the view
does not seem confident that Jack
Smith's going to be able to bring this
home I agree if they're fantasizing
about some sort of ridiculous plea where
he goes and lives in Greece it just
seems like Trump's traveled more to
arraignments than Biden's traveled to
swing States he's been zigzagging all
over the east coast and Biden's been
asleep or at least like in Delaware
reading a book it doesn't look good for
Joe Biden right now I'm starting to
agree with Greg I hate to say that signs
are pointing that he might not be the
nominee and I want to bring up what you
said about Barr
some really smart lawyer earlier on Fox
said that if they're going to bring in
Barr as a witness they get to cross bar
and say okay well you told Trump there
was no election fraud what'd you do to
investigate it how many man hours did
you spend how much money did you spend
where did you go what did those
lieutenants tell you I mean you can't
say everything's fine it was like two
weeks he checked for fraud okay
everybody has the right to be suspicious
in this country if you have a covid
election where they blow out all of the
signature requirements they blow out all
of the deadlines and then they blast out
all these unsolicited ballots into the
ecosystem with no chain of custody
you're not suspicious you have a right
to be suspicious and all these state
legislators had no power to do anything
about it it was just done via judicial
Fiat and then Zuckerberg lands I think
it was a half a billion layers over all
of these election volunteers all over
the state worker acted these people were
activists that were running this thing
so if someone sends you an affidavit
that says there's Monkey Business in
Detroit the president has every legal
right to call the you know Michigan
State Legislature and say can you guys
look into this maybe you want to send an
alternative slate of electors for me and
by the way it's not a big deal to send
an alternative slate of electors you
know what they did when like what a half
dozen uh alternate electors came in they
had the real ones
then they got the alternative ones and
then they just threw the other ones in
the trash that's it it didn't it didn't
mean anything it's just an alternative
elector that's it
but Jesse nope nope no president has
ever done that before well they did it
in Hawaii in 1960. they had an
alternative slate
it's fine it's been done before and the
other thing is like why can't you just
ask Mike Pence to do that did you said
no an election from 1916. you're not
Jesse Waters take off that mask how long
have they been a state I'm researching
too much uh president Trump's as you can
see the plane they're lining up on the
tarmac and he is about to depart back to
New Jersey can I make a point I hate to
do this because I go into the view for
political Insight it's like going to
McDonald's for tofu but they said
something that was true and that is it's
not about an election or a crime it's
about taking them off the board it's
like they just want him to go away they
just want him to go away and it's like
playing a team in which he's the best
player that they got sorry Republicans
but where's the where are the others and
uh and so they just want to take them
off so they just actually told the truth
that they're willing to do anything to
get rid of them because they can't play
fair I agree with you yeah and that's
you can't do that as an American we know
the Constitution requires a couple
things to run for president and it's not
to be approved by The View you have to
be a certain age yeah you have to be
born in America you have to be an
American citizen Democrats or anyone who
wish something like that in their
political opponent is just that's
Un-American you have to beat someone one
of the other thing is that I've been
noticing Ballot Box and let me just ask
you about this Greg is that the the
Democrats are constantly so disappointed
and disgusted with Republicans because
they keep saying like if you listen to
NPR for example they'll say they just
cannot believe that Republicans would
stick with them even after all these
indictments like even after all of these
legal problems and they stick with them
and they cannot figure it out that's a
terrible impression of npreneur I can't
believe I'll give it a try next time
although I listen at 1.5 speed to get it
over with faster why are Republicans
still sticking to the person that we
can't stand we hate him so much why
don't they hate him too it's because you
hate him so much that they love him
because he scares you because they
support him that's the whole thing so
the more you throw this stuff at them
again like I said yesterday it's spinach
to Popeye you know the more you the more
indictments the impeachments by the way
that impeachment's got to feel pretty
weird right now the first impeachment
the perfect phone call when it turns out
he was dead right think about that yeah
Shannon bream what is the next step in
the legal process will his team make a
motion to what well August what is it
28th is the next um hearing so this
judge is not wasting time I mean they
want to move this thing forward as far
as the D.C case is concerned but there
are going to be so many pre-trial
motions I think venues going to come up
I don't think it'll work but they're
going to try it I think all kinds of
other emotions the Mar-A-Lago case
because there are classified documents
and so many things involved there that
you gotta vet before you get to a jury
there's a lot of pre-trial wrangling
that's going to happen in that one as
well we talked to Georgia Georgia we
wait now because we're in this kind of
two-week window that we think if there's
going to be an indictment from the
special grand jury there it'll come so
that could be any time and that is the
one that includes the mug shot that's
the the sheriff has pledged if there is
an indictment of President Trump he will
get a mug shot in Georgia unlike these
Federal cases and that will be the most
uh the probably the most profitable
t-shirt ever made we talked about mug
shots last week Dana you weren't here
but we talked about do you practice for
your mug shot would you I've thought
about it you've got to be prepared you
want to be smiling but not like a crazy
person but smiling like a medicine yeah
do you remember Tom delays mugshot yes
anyway Gen X or gen Z look at Tom DeLay
DL he's probably watching right now
going why are you bringing this up all
right president Trump said to take off
after pleading not guilty in four
federal charges hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else